en este vídeo veremos cómo encontrar la
pendiente de una recta encontrar la
pendiente de una recta no es tan difícil
sólo tienen que aprenderse una fórmula
que dice que para encontrar la pendiente
que por alguna razón la identificamos
con la letra m se define como el cambio
en las coordenadas y es decir ye todos
menos uno entre x2 menos x1 y podemos
decir que eso es igual a la elevación
entre la longitud o también podemos
abreviarlo como delta y entre delta x es
decir el cambio en g entre el cambio en
x bueno en este caso tenemos el punto 12
y 54 entonces si queremos encontrar la
pendiente miren a simple vista podemos
ver que se eleva un par de unidades que
la podemos abreviar como del talle
porque es el cambio en ye y observen que
también nos desplazamos todo
que sería nuestra delta x así que
podríamos contar estos espacios y
encontraremos la pendiente entonces
primero nos dice cuántas unidades nos
elevamos bueno si empezamos con dos y
terminamos en cuatro entonces
necesitamos subir dos unidades en este
caso necesitamos subir dos unidades
el cambio en g es igual a dos y la
longitud nos dice que tanto nos movemos
horizontalmente en este caso empezamos
con 1 y tenemos que avanzar hasta 1 2 3
4 5 entonces avanzamos 1 2 3 4 unidades
así que nuestra pendiente es un medio ok
ahora otra forma de llegar al mismo
resultado es identificando los datos y
usar la ecuación de la pendiente por
ejemplo este dato es nuestra x 1 y este
es nuestro 1 y como este es el segundo
punto este
x2 y este es jet 2 y nos dicen que para
calcular la pendiente
podemos usar esta fórmula entonces jet2
es igual a 4 y a eso le vamos a restar
de 1 que en este caso es 2 así que al
restar las coordenadas de y nos queda 2
ese es el cambio en ye y para el cambio
en x tenemos 5 menos uno eso es igual a
cuatro y esto es igual a un medio justo
lo que obtuvimos antes así que no está
tan complicado solo recuerden la fórmula
y bueno además aquí fue muy fácil
trabajar con estos números pero hagamos
algo más complicado
y miren si la recta se eleva de
izquierda a derecha entonces tenemos una
pendiente positiva y si obtuvimos una
pendiente positiva ok
hagamos otro ahora con números
diferentes supongamos que este punto
tiene las coordenadas 1.5 y 2.3
es nuestro primer punto 1 punto 5,23 y
supongamos que el segundo punto es 5
comer
5 - 1.7 bueno en este caso no está tan
fácil contar los espacios pero sabemos
que esto es x 1 y esto es 1 y por acá
tenemos x 2 y jet2 y miren si conectamos
los puntos de la recta podemos ver que
decrece por lo tanto la pendiente será
negativa si no tenemos un resultado
negativo sabremos que hicimos algo más
ahora ya sabemos que la pendiente es
igual a la resta de las coordenadas y no
importa si definimos a estas coordenadas
como x 1 ig1 en lugar de que fueran x
2-2 y que éstas fueran x1 y 1 de
cualquier manera obtendremos el mismo
resultado
entonces para este caso 10 2 es menos
1.7 y a eso le restamos que 1 que es 2.3
y todo eso entre x2 que es 5 - x 1 que
es 1.5 y ahora simplemente hacemos
la aritmética menos 1.7
2.3 es igual a menos 4 y 5
1.5 es igual a 3.5 esta es nuestra
pendiente y generalmente la pendiente
tiene números enteros entonces para
deshacernos de los decimales podemos
multiplicar tanto el numerador como el
denominador por 10 si hacemos eso nos
queda menos 40 entre 35 y si dividimos
los dos números entre 5 podemos reducir
esto a menos 8 entre 7 está es la
pendiente de nuestra recta menos 8 entre
7 ok y bueno calcular la pendiente es
algo muy común en matemáticas y ahora
podrán calcular las pendientes sin
ningún problema y también la van a
necesitar para encontrar ecuaciones de
rectas así que espero que estos dos
ejemplos les sirvan